سفينه ناقله للغاز في ظاهرها وحبل نجاه في
باطنها تشبثت فيه المانيا لتتدارك الغرق
في بحر نقص الطاقه بعد وقف تلقي شحنات
الغاز الروسيه على اثر الحرب في اوكرانيا
السفينه الاولى من نوعها في المانيا هي
محطه عائمه للغاز المسال دشناها المستشار
اولاش جلد في بحر الشمال ليتمكنوا من
استيراد وتخزين الغاز الطبيعي السفينه تعد
اول محطه ضمن 5 محطات عائمه ستطلق العام
الجاري لتغطيه ثلث احتياجات المانيا عبر
30 مليار متر مكعب من الغازي سنويا
يستهلكها 50,000 منزل
حلوا وجدت فيه برلين املا ببدايه حل ازمه
الطاقه على الرغم من الاخطار المحدقه بين
تقلبات السوق على الامد القصير في الحصول
على غزه وبين فصل الشتاء اضافه الى
المشاكل البيئيه التي قد تتسبب بها في
سبيل تجنب التكاليف الباهظه لنقل الغازي
عبر الموانئ
وهذه المحطه تساعدنا اما العيوب فهناك
الكثير من المشاكل
ايهما نضحي به اولا بالاقتصاد ام البيئه
خياران ضيقان مساحه الحلول على المسؤولين
الالمانيين لمواجهه ازمه الغاز وسطت تزايد
الضغوط الداخليه لوضع حلل امثال امل
الرويشد العربيه